hey there so have you ever heard about
The Crucible cast 9 technique this is a
revolutionizing technique in the field
of genetic engineering which can easily
and precisely cut the gene at your
preferred site
technique was developed by two ladies
named as Jennifer jogner and Emilia
chaprante they have developed this
technique in 2012 and were also awarded
Nobel Prize in the year of 2020 in
chemistry this technique can help us
treat the genetic disorders such as
sickle cell anemia hunting tongue
disease as well as cystic fibrosis
that's not all this technique was also
used for creating the albino monkey with
complete white fur the potential of
these techniques are too vast and can be
explored to the fullest well to get
information about such more fun
interesting topics stay tuned with us
and do like share and subscribe